what i want to do in this video is try
to get a better understanding of the
structure of the earth and we're
actually going to think about it in two
different ways so let me just draw half
of the earth over here
that's my best shot at drawing half of a
circle and what we're going to do is
think about in two ways and on the left
hand side we're going to think about it
as the compositional layers or the
chemical layers so over here we're going
to think about the chemical
the chemical structure or the
composition or the composition
composition of the layer and on the
right hand side we're going to think
about the mechanical properties of the
layer and when i say the mechanical
properties i'm really just saying is
that layer kind of a solid rigid layer
is it kind of a liquid layer or is it
something in between a kind of a
putty like non-rigid solid layer so
let's think about it on the chemical or
the compositional side first because to
some degree this is simpler so the
outermost layer is the crust that's the
layer that we're sitting on right here
right now i'm assuming assuming you're
on the planet so this right here is the
crust it is the outermost it's obviously
solid we'll think about that when we
talk about the mechanical side of things
and it's also the thinnest layer and
crust is not uniform there's both
oceanic crust and continental crust let
me draw the crust on this side as well
so let me draw some crust over here
we've got some crust right over there
and there is both oceanic crust and
continental crust so oceanic crust is
thinner crust so let's say that this
part right here let me draw some thicker
crust
let me draw some thicker crust right
over here we'll call the thicker stuff
the continental crust
which is thicker and less dense than the
oceanic crust so what i'm doing in this
light green color this is continental
so this right here is continental
continental
and then in this kind of more
fluorescent green this is oceanic
oceanic crust and the oceanic crust is
pretty thin it's on the order of about
five or ten kilometers so let's just
call this
this is approximately five to ten
kilometers
thick and when i talk about oceanic
crust i'm not talking about the oceans
i'm talking about the liquid part the
water i'm talking about the rock that
kind of holds the water the rock
underneath the oceans and so this is
five to ten kilometers thick if you were
to go to the bottom of the ocean and you
were to kind of sit on the rock and then
drill you'd have to drill about five to
ten kilometers to get through that layer
this compositional layer
so this is five to ten kilometers and
the continental crust is about 10 to 70
kilometers thick
to 70 kilometers thick and obviously
they are both rigid they are both solid
solid rock now below when you think
about composition or the what what what
the layers are made up of the next layer
below that this is actually the biggest
layer of the earth by volume is the
mantle
is the mantle so let me draw it like
that i always have trouble drawing the
right hand side of this
circle so let me draw
so this is the mantle right over here
let me write down this is all
this is all the mantle and once again we
differentiate it from the crust because
it's composed of different types of rock
now you go even deeper and let me give
you the depth here so the mantle starts
right below the crust right below the
oceanic and the continental crust
oceanic and continental and it goes
about 2929
kilometers deeper so it's much much much
thicker than the crust the crust is on
the order of uh uh
five to maybe 70 kilometers thick this
is a a
much much thicker so even even though
i've drawn the crust fairly thin it i
didn't draw thin enough relative to how
thick i've drawn the mantle this isn't
drawn to scale now you go even deeper
than that you get kind of the densest
part of the earth and that is the core
that is the core and there's going to be
a couple of themes here especially when
we think about the mechanical properties
of the earth is the deeper you get the
deeper you get you're going to get
denser elements and you're going to have
more heat and more pressure and the
reason why you're going to have denser
elements is when earth was first forming
and it was kind of in its molten state
the denser elements just kind of sunk to
the bottom and the lighter elements
would sink would kind of rise to the top
they would have this buoyancy because
they're
they're less dense than everything
around it and really the you know even
the gases would kind of bubble up would
essentially bubble up and form our
atmosphere so that's why in general the
densest things are in the center and the
least dense things are on the outside
they're in our atmosphere and the core
once again its composition is
fundamentally different than the mantle
and the crust we believe that is mainly
metals and in in particular iron and
nickel so that's the structure the
layers of the earth from a composition
point of view from a chemical point of
view now let's kind of think about the
same layers but we're going to think
more in terms of what's liquid what's
rigid in solid and what's in between
so the outermost rigid layer of the
earth the outermost rigid layer of the
earth is made up of the crust both the
continental and the oceanic crust and
the the kind of the coolest top layer of
the of the mantle so let me draw that
let me draw that in pink
so this layer right over here
so what i'm drawing in pink is the cool
rigid solid part of the mantle
so this is the cool
so it is solid rock the part of the
mantle that's solid rock its composition
is different than say the continental
crust but they are both rigid so if you
combine this this topmost this topmost
layer of the mantle with the crust then
you're talking about the lithosphere
so this is the lithosphere
the lithosphere and this essentially
gets you about the lithosphere depending
on where you are i mean we depending on
where you are on on the surface of the
earth is 10 to 200 kilometers thick
so 10 to 200
kilometers thick and most most of the
time it's closer to the high end of this
range the tan is kind of where
you have hot spots in the mantle it's
essentially been able to kind of
dissolve parts of the lithosphere and
essentially create new we'll talk more
about that when we talk about the actual
plate tectonics of it all and when we
talk about plate tectonics the plates
are actually lithospheric plates it's
actually the lithosphere that's moving
on top of the lower layer the lower
layers of the mantle so that the
lithosphere it is rigid it is solid it's
made up of the crust and the upper layer
of the mantle the uppermost layer of the
mantle now you go a little bit deeper
the temperatures and the pressures
increase but now the temperatures have
increased enough you have the same
composition as as the uppermost the
rigid part of the mantle but the
temperatures have now gone up enough
that it now turns into not quite a
liquid we won't call it a liquid it
actually still
transmits the type of waves that liquids
would not transmit it's more of like a
putty type texture something it has
fluid properties it can flow it's way
more viscous than what we would
associate with most fluids but it's so
it's not rigid and solid it can have
convection going on in it but it's not a
liquid it still will transmit certain
types of waves that liquids won't and
this is called the asthenosphere kind of
this jelly putty layer and it's that
it's just it's it's it's like that
because it's so hot that the rock is
somewhat melted so this is
this layer right here in magenta is the
asthenosphere
asthenosphere i've seen some spellings
where there's an e after the a i think
that's due that's maybe the european
spelling and the aesthetic sphere
obviously starts right below the
lithosphere it's what the lithospheric
plates when we talk about plate
tectonics are riding on top of it's kind
of the gummy material that allows it to
actually move that allows the rigid
layer to actually move on top and it
goes so it starts below the starts below
the lithosphere and it ends at around
660 kilometers deep so this right here
is
660 kilometers
deep and then you go even deeper than
that and now the pressures are so big
that even though the temperatures are
even higher even the temperatures are
either higher the pressures are so big
that
what that the same material can't have
fluid motion anymore it's essentially
been jammed together so you can imagine
if you have things
that are somewhat fluid they can they
can kind of that means that they can the
molecules can kind of slide past each
other maybe very slowly but if you
increase the pressure enough
if you increase the pressure enough
they'll be jammed into each other and
that's essentially what happens in the
next layer of the mantle all of these
layers of the mantle are made up of the
same thing it's just a difference of
temperature and pressure and so that
next layer of the mantle is called the
mesosphere
meso
it's called the mesosphere and you
shouldn't you shouldn't uh
this is called the mesosphere but
there's also a layer of our atmosphere
that's called the layer right above the
stratosphere that's called the
mesosphere and so don't get confused
here these are two different mesospheres
and this layer the pressure is so big
that now we are rigid again we are kind
of you know definitely solid none of
this debate about you know a little bit
of fluid motion because the pressures
are so big now you go a little bit
deeper you go a little bit deeper we are
now in the core the the metallic core
and the temperatures are so high
that even though the pressures are high
because we have a compositional change
we are at pressures where this type of
mesospheric rock is rigid but
metallic but metals at these
temperatures actually can be fluid can
actually be liquid and so we actually
have a liquid
we actually have a liquid outer core
liquid outer
liquid outer core the entire core as far
as we know is made up of the same stuff
just the outer part of the core the
temperatures are high enough to melt the
the metal but the pressures aren't so
high enough to make them solid the
pressures are definitely high enough to
make kind of more rocky material solid
but not the metals and then you go even
deeper now the pressure even though the
temperature keeps going up the pressure
is so strong that even the metals are
solid so this is the solid
solid
inner core so when you think about the
mechanical properties the innermost and
just so you know the total distances
we're talking about the outer core
starts at let me i actually didn't tell
you where the mesosphere
so the mesosphere ends sorry the the
mantle ends at about 2 900 kilometers
deep so that's clearly where the
mesosphere ends as well because the
mesosphere is kind of the lower mantle
so this is 2 900 kilometers
deep then you go even deeper you're in
the liquid outer core and that extends
from about 2 900 kilometers deep to
about 5 100 kilometers deep
so i really should
i frankly should make the liquid core in
my drawing even wider
so this extends to about
this depth right over here is about 5100
kilometers deep and then obviously then
you have the center of the earth and the
entire radius of the earth is about 6
400 kilometers so hopefully that
clarifies things when you hear people
talking about the lithosphere or the
mantle that they're really talking about
mechanical versus composition when we
talk about mechanical solid inner core
liquid outer core
essentially solid mesosphere it's rigid
then you have a something kind of a
spongy somewhat fluid not solid not
liquid asthenosphere that the
lithospheric plates can ride on top of
and then you have your actual rigid
solid lithosphere made up of the
uppermost part of the mantle and the
crust